there's no long-term strategic thinking
what are you going to do in 10 years you
have no idea dude I have some ideas you
have no idea I went from 10 years ago
would have been just as convinced that
you would know where you'd be today and
this is nowhere close
actually surprisingly closer than I
thought if you're close then you're
thinking small because you have no idea
what you're capable of in a 10-year
window like if you can pinpoint now
where you're going to be in 2033 I'm
pissed the only way to have long term
strategic thinking is if you're in a
very stable set boring life I'm at a law
firm and I'm going to be junior partner
and then Senior partner and like the
life has been mapped out for you that's
the only way to have long-term strategic
thinking but in terms of chess moves you
have no idea the grand Masters can think
15 moves ahead but beginners can only
think three but chess has rules life has
no rules if you plan 10 years out you're
operating from 2023 rules and maybe 2024
if you're like super genius but we're
going to be in 10 years who knows dude
so one thing we have noticed with our
demographics primarily women okay that
are their Dream Chasers they want to be
entrepreneurs a lot of them are very
emotionally driven Alan as a coach will
help them become more logically driven
what
from your perspective what do people
need more of do they need to tap into
and I know it's a blanket statement but
do they need to tap into their emotions
or do they need to understand the
logical side of success where you get a
little bit better like what's your take
on logic versus emotion
I think everybody's emotional and then
we use logic to kind of justify why
we're doing something
I think my solution has been I used to I
if you had asked me this I don't know 20
years ago I would have said I'm a
logical person but I'm actually
emotional
and then use logic to help me and I
think the answer becomes big decisions
with the hearts problems with the head
the big decisions in your life should be
emotional decisions
why are you starting this business why
are you who are you with as a partner
like these are emotional decisions like
if you guys are going together because
of logic it's going to fall apart which
is what happened if you're starting this
show because a podcast is like the thing
to do in 2023 like right it's over like
forget it you've lost right so emotion
has to be at the foundation level but
emotion alone doesn't doesn't do
anything you then need to use your brain
to help you figure out okay how do I
actually go off and do it so I love Alan
awesome what are we going to do together
well you know you're not just gonna hey
I love hanging out with you let's hang
out
right they're like or we're going to
start a podcast like okay well we need
we need the topic we need a camera we
need like you use your head to help you
figure out how to do the thing
but I think everybody
has both and needs both and I think
ultimately even people who identify as
logical are actually emotional at the
core and then just are buried in logic
to help justify their emotions
how do you help somebody and it can be
you personally how do you help somebody
take the medicine that they don't think
they want or they don't think they need
usually the thing that's holding us back
is the thing that we want the least if
we wanted it we'd already have the
result how do you help somebody adopt
hey you need to be more emotional or
more logical with this
uh
back to you know previous episode they
need to be above ground so if they're
like buried deep underground and hate
their life and like just toxic
everywhere around they can't they can't
hear that message of here's what you
need to fix there's like there's no way
so you're you're meeting where they're
at you're hugging them you're
encouraging them you're even though you
know like they're screwing up in a
million ways it's too raw you can't
touch that because it like they're gonna
start screaming and freaking out right
so you have to get them to the point
like if somebody is all like raw and
skin and bone like they can't go off and
start working out like heal your crazy
wounds dude before you get in the pool
and start swimming or something right so
like that's the part most people at the
beginning need to heal their wounds so
that they're ready for the next step
uh once they're once they're there then
it's about uh trust and Rapport like do
you know what they want are you actually
pushing them on the thing that they want
versus the thing you would do right one
of my favorite things to do when I'm
when I'm talking about coaching people I
have a analogy that I call wear their
skin
so like I'm telling you what Kevin
should do not what Evan would do in
Kevin's shoes
I become you
but like better you
future you empowered you fully believe
you and it's like and then and then it
resonates because I'm just holding up a
truth mirror
where this sometimes takes on really
weird things like I'll give advice that
I would never take myself
I will
um I'll sometimes swear at people it's
like wow I remember one woman who was
coached she's like I've never heard you
swear before it's like I didn't I didn't
swear that was you
like I'm you I was wearing you yeah it's
like yeah it's like wearing their skin
it feels that's one of the things we
talked before about things that people
can connect this is a harder thing to
connect to but when I'm when I'm when I
was yelling at you in the lobby that
wasn't me that was you yelling at
yourself how is that intuitive where you
can get a read on me and say this is
exactly what Kevin how do you know I
don't know like I think the best if I I
haven't done um I haven't done a deep
dive to kind of analyze that right it's
like how do you how do you hit a
baseball I don't know like it comes and
you swing right a lot of the best
hitters like Ted Williams was the
greatest hitter of all time but he
sucked as a coach he couldn't transfer
that skill to other people so I haven't
codified that in a in a great way the
easiest starting point is to figure out
their one word right to figure out what
their most important core value is
because it if it's actually who they are
that's the push
you know like when it uses resilience
again right so if
you know like well you didn't do the
thumbnails but like that how resilient
is that Kevin
right it's like you're giving them I
wouldn't use that word right but that's
not me so in in identifying that they're
giving you the leverage to help them
so a lot of people end up using your one
word or we go through it built to serve
too to uh to their teams so that if you
know what that person is all about
it gives you the leverage to be able to
push them on the thing that they care
the most about so understanding the most
important core value understanding their
mission and what they're trying to
accomplish and then understanding where
they're at because you could have those
two things but you're also like you just
lost your dog or something right
like the only time I didn't film videos
was when my dog died
I filmed videos through broken neck
concussion all of it but when my dog
died I didn't that's the only week I've
like taken off and didn't film videos
uh and if you came in and said Evan
that's not very believe and like Fu dude
like I don't care like my dog died I
need to heal from this and so we can't
judge other people might have it swapped
like I would never film if I'm in the
hospital with a broken neck but who
cares about my dog I don't know right so
it's understanding their emotional state
understanding their mission
understanding the most important core
value and like in that cocktail it gives
you the recipe to be able to to push
them how much inner work have you done
you know it's like one of those things
that never gets old
um is it hard for you to start that
because it seems like you're very good
at external was it hard for you to dig
inside and say I'm gonna work on Evan
no
um
I I love taking on new things like you
have a different modality that you want
to no nobody's models ever quite fit me
so it's cool but I'm happy to try on the
next model you guys you have your
eight-step personality test cool I'm a
electrifier awesome
you know like it never quite fits but
all of them are good
good pass like I'm not locked into one
modality like it's got to be the Colby
score it's got to be the Myers-Briggs
there's got to be the whatever but they
all teach you a little bit about
yourself even even down to
I just had my DNA tested and from the
DNA test they show you hey based on your
genes you're more susceptible to these
kinds of foods and this kind of activity
and all this kind of stuff like okay
those are like their averages so it's
it's a good starting point I love trying
stuff I love trying stuff for me to
learn and also to to demonstrate to
other people that go try stuff like I
had a woman come in and and do um EFT on
me you know UFC tapping yeah yeah like I
didn't know what it was uh so she's an
EFT okay cool let's let's go let's do it
so we sat here and I tapped on my
whatever and did all the stuff okay cool
um I had Marissa Pierre do hypnotherapy
on me in a live session she was going to
disappear but she was in UK and we did
it over zoom and it's like okay lie down
on the floor like okay it was just a
camera here am I lying on the floor and
then she lost her internet connection
halfway through so I'm still like Lana
don't be done is it still happening
right but I I love as long as it's not
like hurting somebody or if I'm gonna
throw somebody like what I won't do is
throw somebody under the bus like I
won't do a live therapy session that
like digs into my parents or something
right that's where I would like hurting
somebody else or potentially hurting
somebody else is where I would draw the
line on it or something on my cause
physical pain I guess but apart from
that like any question or any
personality test or any modality like
everything is a it's too part of me
learning more but also if we make it
public it's showing other people I did a
session with garyvee's life coach Beth
Handel and if you heard her but
um first off like Gary B has a life
coach I thought he was a life coach like
this is cool like whoever's coaching him
I want to talk to her let's see what
happens and they asked me to fill out
this intake questionnaire before they do
a session
and I said uh let's just do it live like
I don't ask me those questions live and
they're like oh but they're like really
personal questions and like nobody wants
us to be on YouTube and like no no I do
you know like just ask for the questions
live like are you sure it's like yeah
yeah we'll just do a lot and so like the
whole the whole intake process Plus in
her advice was all on the session we
didn't edit anything out I like that
right like I think it when it makes me
feel good that like oh other people
aren't doing it okay cool I'm gonna do
it let's go I'm strong enough to do this
let's go hoorah
but then also uh it hopefully serves
other people watching this show like hey
therapy is not bad self-exploration
isn't bad doing personality tests isn't
bad like try it out see what fits
um
so whatever if you said like hey before
we start the show we all have to like
touch this Crystal and and say something
three times in a row and dance in a
circle okay whatever let's see your
style and if it works then hey guys this
Crystal is the thing or it's like those
guys have some weird techniques but cool
it works for them that's not judging
like it I believe that it works for you
cool like I remember going I wanted to
one of Tony's thing is um he had this
guy come in and was doing like energy
work and and it's like you rub your
hands together and then like feel the
energy ball between your hands and then
like wider and like feel the energy and
then like put your hand over the person
next to you and feel their energy and
it's like and I'm doing it like I feel
nothing I don't feel any energy my hands
getting higher I feel nothing I put my
hand over Nina's head nothing like I I'm
I'm not getting it like it's not working
um but but I believe that other people
had the experience right like when other
people are like oh man that was crazy
like oh like that's awesome like I
didn't experience I didn't experience it
so I'm not gonna lie and say that was
great but I'm also that's all Bs like I
believe that that thing worked for you I
just haven't figured out the way for it
to work for me yet
which one do you think you're more well
developed in logic long-term strategic
thinking rationality or emotion I don't
think there is there's no long-term
strategic thinking
what's long term what are you going to
do in 10 years you have no idea dude
I have some ideas you have no idea
from Tesco would have been just as
convinced that you would know where
you'd be today
and this is nowhere close
it's actually surprisingly closer than I
thought if you're if you're close then
you're thinking small
because you have no idea what you're
capable of in a 10-year window
like if you can pinpoint now where
you're going to be in 2033 or whatever
dude like I'm pissed
be president
not like have X number of people
following you or some BS metric or
whatever is actually on your list for 10
like there is no long term for did you
thinking
the only way to have long term strategic
thinking is if you're in a very stable
set boring life like I'm at a I'm at a
law firm and I'm going to be junior
partner and then Senior partner and like
the life has been mapped out for you
that's the only way to have long-term
strategic thinking you hate your life
it's all been mapped out for you but in
terms of chess moves you have no idea
the grand Masters can think 15 moves
ahead but beginners can only think three
but chess it has rules yeah life has no
rules you're you're operating from if
you plan 10 years out you're operating
from 2023 rules
and maybe 2024 if you're like super
genius but we're going to be in 10 years
who knows dude
there is no long-term strategic thing
like only on major macro Trends right if
you said AI is going to be a big deal in
10 years okay cool what does that mean
for you I don't know create a virtual
reality school maybe but maybe maybe you
should be president
and you're up running your stupid
virtual reality school but I'm not told
I'm not called for that but you're not
called for it yet
oh that's the problem like so ultimately
there's nothing wrong with having wrong
with having 10-year goals
what's wrong is not jumping off after
year two because you found something
better right well I'm presupposing
pivots and evolution but you can't you
can't like then you don't know where
you're gonna be in 10 years you have to
have the flexibility to jump off and say
this is better right but you have to
have the clarity and the certainty to
move forward to gain momentum so that
you go get more clarity and then allow
it to evolve and flexible or be
comfortable moving forward without
certainty
Fair
because you don't know where you're
going to be in 10 years like if I said
uh
I'm gonna have uh 10 million subscribers
on my YouTube channel in 10 years cool
like I should probably jump off and
start doing VR after year four
like Screw YouTube maybe I should be
doing something else
do you want to have 10 million
subscribers no I care about impact I
want to I want to sell the world's
biggest problem that's all that matters
like you have a goal you got a big
mission and you do whatever it takes to
hit that mission and that requires a
million pivots along the way sure
so it's a goal so big that I'm not gonna
I'm never gonna accomplish that it's an
infinite game impossible to solve never
gonna happen and I wake up every day
trying to make that thing happen and
that's the only thing that counts I like
it we I think the best you can plan is
like three months ahead
10 years like forget it so whether it
was long term I don't know what we
didn't Define long term but it's like
the fact that you hit you hit close to
what you said tenure pisses me off
that 10 years ago you like nailed where
you're gonna what if I what if I'm
behind you're way behind dude you're way
behind us a thousand miles behind what
you should have been I agree because you
stuck to a plan that you should have
kicked out three years in how do you
know I didn't pivot
because just because you're here because
you're not Nostradamus because where you
were 10 years ago you in 20 how what
year is it 2020 to 2023 in 2013 there's
no way 2013 Allen knows anything about
anything about 2023 Alan except for the
fact that I ended up a business
consultant which I did want to do in my
early 20s
great
the path was different but the
destination the destiny I think was more
aligned than I anticipated
cool now the challenge going forward the
next 10 years is more variation and
forget the 10-year plan and who cares
about business consultancy and go be
president
or whatever
it's bigger it's you're capable of doing
more and you have no idea especially in
the 10 years that you have no idea
what's going to happen
you have a bag of Doritos on your desk
what so some people like that thank you
some people might say that and they say
that's a sponsorship or an ad for
Doritos what is the logical and
emotional decision for you doing
something like that
I don't know there's a logical one
um you know the emotional one is I I
feel like I'm amazing every time I look
at the Doritos bag because it's a
reminder that damn the Doritos because I
want to eat it and I'm not going to eat
it you know so I I want to make choices
that make me feel stronger and I want to
eliminate the decisions and thought
process and choices that make me feel
weaker and worse about myself and this
is an achiever Navy Seals mindset that's
harder for most people to to think about
anytime I feel like this thing is making
me weaker I want to eliminate it so the
Doritos thing is about having junk food
in the house you're on a diet get rid of
the junk food that's a crutch cool but
the gold becomes to walk and to run
eventually so you've trained yourself to
only be perfect in a certain environment
and then that's it then you go on a
vacation or Cruise or business
conference or whatever you run for
president you're going to eat like junk
all the time and it's over because you
train yourself you only win a certain
environment right I don't want to do
that I want to train myself to have
control and crush it wherever I go
um same thing for like the phone next to
the people say and this this is also
very counter to what most of my
contemporaries are saying right like put
the phone in the other room
so in the morning you wake up and you
have to get out of bed and go turn off
the phone and logically like that makes
sense like yeah that makes sense it gets
me out of bed
I'll go turn off the phone and now I'm
out of bed and I'm already up and you
know so I'm gonna stay up right
logically that makes sense as a strategy
emotionally when I connect to it I hate
it me personally because I'm telling
myself I'm not capable of just getting
out of bed so I need this little crutch
and that pisses me off now I don't wake
up to an alarm or like need it most of
the time so
um that's not my problem but if it was
like I'm gonna I'm gonna have the phone
right next to me I'm gonna like damn
this phone I'm waking up I'm having one
alarm not 14 that I'm snoozing a
thousand times right and then I'm gonna
get out of bed right so the way that I I
see those things like the snooze button
for me I see it as you're telling
yourself that you suck
like you said a goal last night the last
thing you do at night is say I'm going
to wake up at eight o'clock this morning
tomorrow morning and the first thing
you're saying is say nope my goal is
today you just screwed like your whole
day up right like to rebound out of that
is really hard
so I think like you're hitting the
snooze button you're hitting the snooze
on your life
so but I'll take things to extremes like
that and that may not be like the
reality for most people right have you
ever eaten the Doritos
uh I've never opened the bag that was in
my office uh I've I've uh
yeah like I've intentionally had like
I've had a Dorito like since right
um
but I like to use it as as Leverage is
there a place that you're trying to do
that right now that you're struggling in
uh if I knew it I would I would do it
um
the biggest thing would be not have any
awareness
as soon as I as soon as it bubbles up to
awareness and like it's I did action
great things fell through me we're doing
something about this but I'm sure
there's a million things that are like
subconscious bubbling beneath that like
I can't even identify that that's where
you know it gets pulled out somebody
asked me like if you had time with Tony
Robbins what would you ask him what
questions like I wouldn't ask him I want
him to ask me questions pull on
something that I don't even know exists
and like open my eyes because once I
know it I'll go and
take immediate action against it that
was my next question which is who is
the guide for you in terms of
pushing your buttons and and you also
I'll read from the question you talked
about the why you do what you do is the
heart and how you actually go about
doing it is the brain
um what was the why and how when you
first started
did you know that YouTube was going to
be the how and and was the why Always
because of your deepest pain regarding
entrepreneurship and how has that
shifted since yeah I didn't know I mean
a lot of it uh in my first business was
more
my first visit was biotech software and
it was more I didn't want to miss out
there's more fear of regret I would
rather like take the 100K job offer or
start this business and make 300 bucks a
month and own 30 of it
you know logically like okay go to take
the job but emotionally I didn't want to
miss out so even if the most likely
outcome was failure I still wanted to at
least try so I know so I wouldn't be an
old man at 40 and like hate my life that
I didn't do this thing so I I took that
was this pre.com like dot combo 19
1999 okay so this is like right at the
height of the.com bubble I don't
remember too okay but 1999 2000
um I was in university and kind of
figuring out what to do next so I didn't
have a mission I didn't know purpose
comes from your pain I didn't have a lot
of mentors or guides I wasn't really
reading a lot of personal development or
as like very surface level book every
now and then but it wasn't a habit by
any stretch I just I just did not want
to live with regret there was a
something from Jeff Bezos who's like
regret minimization strategy whereas
like just try to live life with as few
regrets as possible so I figured what
would I regret more and like okay so I'm
gonna at least try so that I know even
if it failed that I tried that was the
main reason it was no like purpose
changed the world it's like I find this
fun and I want to regret if I don't do
it
it's a very simple basic you know so
that's how we started when I we built it
sold it you know had a lot of struggles
we can dive in if you want but then
ultimate success sold it awesome I
didn't know what to do next
and I tried a whole bunch of different
things and the thing that just stuck was
trying to help out other entrepreneurs
in hindsight it's easy to say purpose
comes from your pain you struggle as an
entrepreneur you want to help other
entrepreneurs like that makes logical
sense if I was guiding somebody now I
said you want to help entrepreneurs you
should go do this thing I fumbled around
and tried to figure out a whole bunch of
things and that was just one thing that
I liked that ended up sticking
the more I got into it the more I
learned the more I had more aspirational
mentors and real life mentors who's
kicking my ass while Oprah's kicking my
ass and Steve Jobs is kicked my ass and
Elon Musk is kicking my ass more than a
human that I'm talking to as much as
I've got to and maybe it's on me like a
lot of the people that I profiled
Brandon burchard and Dean graziosi and
Tom bilyeu and all these guys are I can
message yeah like I just I just messaged
Dean happy birthday I just pushed Tom on
an idea for his channel
um I'm sure I could do a better job of
asking for a help or a push or like hey
what do I suck and like beat me up
um so maybe that's an area of
opportunity uh but at the moment I find
it best
by making the content for my channel
watching the content on my channel and
something something hits like
[Music]
[Laughter]
and all sorts of people like I'm like
Grant Cardone gets me hyped for one
reason and the Dalai Lama gets me hyped
for a different reason like we have all
sorts of weird stuff on the channel but
at all something that I can connect to
in some way and um I've created that
have been a routine for myself so the
the biggest mentors I have are the
people that I profile so like
aspirational mentors more than real life
mentors last question from me let's go
if you're on a podcast and this person
that's interviewing you wants to get you
emotional whatever that means fired up
passionate whatever emotional means what
questions should they ask you ask the
question actually means something to
them
like turn into a coaching session
like the thing that got me the most
fired up in our entire history is like
the whole thumbnail the Buckle scratch
the itch yeah so like where are you I
suppose I think the biggest mistake
podcasters make is they ask questions I
think the audience would care about and
ones that they
care about but like Doritos you already
knew that story that was a question for
the audience not as much like for you so
like kill that and ask a better question
that you care about now I'm getting
already more fired up right
Kevin
a lot of L's for Kevin but it's great
like the fact that there's a lot of push
it's like it's love right it's like
there's all these amazing areas of
opportunity
um just like that video that Alex filmed
and sent me of of the instructors like I
gave her I gave one piece of feedback
for her in like 20 pieces of feedback
for Alex where he wasn't even watching
himself in the video he's watching her
like what should she be doing better and
how can I coach her to be better she's
got it she just needs to be less nervous
you screwed up 20 times here like stop
doing all this other stuff right so yeah
ask the question that you deeply care
about I ran this podcast with Mark
Draeger for maybe two years called uh
something to proved podcast and I would
get the most pissed off at him because
he's always bringing these questions
that he why did I pick you guys because
I thought you would ask me questions
right because you do ask great questions
because you actually care where most
people ask like the same questions that
they think Their audience will care
about but they don't actually have any
real state they're curious It's not that
it's like a throwaway question but it's
like not it's not the real question you
drove here
from Milwaukee and are driving home
overnight and canceled everything you
had for these three days or whatever to
be here like what question can I serve
you with ask that question Kevin that's
what I want to know right and that gets
me you know I'm exaggerating that's the
thing that gets me the most part I think
for any podcaster when you're bringing
somebody on hopefully like you genuinely
care about having this guest on it's not
just some throwaway because there's some
name like you actually care and then ask
them the thing that nobody's asked them
that you deeply care about
can I ask you one more okay and I want
to ask you this but I know you're going
to crap on it I know you are all right
a lot of people will say what what
advice would you give 19 year old Heaven
okay I don't want to ask you that okay
good I want to ask you what advice is 20
years from today Evan gonna give Evan
today it's the same I know I know you're
going to crap out but I had to ask
because I wanted to know but I already
answered that question I know but I
still wanted to ask you why okay why do
you want I already answered that
question in like a previous episode I
want to challenge you to go deeper okay
well then then lead with that okay I
so you say hey you said the advice that
you give today
like the advice 85 year 11 would give 42
11 is to believe more in yourself
I want to challenge you to go deeper
okay cool like lead with that
okay
earlier you said that this version of
Evan would give 19 year old yes how are
we going deeper what do you want to know
what's below that how do you know
nothing's gonna shift I don't know I
don't like that's the big fear
if I knew I would do it I don't have a
problem I'm a quick starter I have no
problem taking immediate action on
something I get an idea let's go do
something it works doesn't work awesome
cool who cares next but I don't know I
don't know I don't I'm doing the best
that I know if I say my biggest problem
is I don't believe in myself enough
right I can make cases for that like why
am I not doing a huge thing compared to
what I'm doing right now it's a lack of
belief it's not a lack of knowledge I
can find knowledge it's not a lack of
mentors I can find mentors it's a lack
of belief to be able to do the next
thing but what is the next thing I don't
know I don't know I don't know if I knew
I would do it I think if you had the
belief you might know and you could
anticipate the future more maybe
like I'm doing the the I'm following my
own advice in that I'm the best way that
I've learned has been through
aspirational mentorship right so like
learning from the from these people
being around like seeing what Elon Musk
is doing with Twitter and and learning
from that through osmosis right and I'm
pulling these pieces and that that has
served me and it's helped me for now
decades and I'm continuing to do it
but it's not as fast as it could be I'm
sure there's other ways that I could
speed that up and I'm constantly open
and looking if you say hey Evan like the
best thing to do is every night you need
to breathe through one nostril upside
down and that's the thing like I'll try
it dude let's go I'm down for nostril
upside down breathing all day long right
if it's going to actually help so I
don't know I'm open I'm hungry like
teach me show me the thing to help me do
the thing I ask people on my shows like
how do you get people to to believe in
themselves more and nobody's had an
answer that feels like it's maybe they
had a great answer and I wasn't
listening to it properly I don't know
I'm but I'm open
um so some people they know what to do
and they're just not doing it
I don't know what to do
I don't know what to do I'm doing
everything that I know how to do and I'm
open to new experiences to do more but I
don't know what that next step is what's
the best way in the past that you've
found out what the next thing to do is
and I know you just answered it it's
aspirational mentors yeah who do you
think in hindsight was the most
aspirational Mentor that had the biggest
impact on you different people taught me
different things right so I like it was
such a variety of people up on the
channel is there anyone who stands out
to you like you do to us
uh well I think I stand out to you
because of the time we've spent together
as well it's not just like you watch my
content and learn something it's also
the actual portion I can say Hey Kevin
like fix this right so no nobody's like
nobody's been that I mean Steve I guess
a little bit my agent helped me in the
early days of making content of pushing
me and seeing what to fix but nobody
from a
from a believe perspective for sure or a
high level business strategy people have
their the problem is people would tell
me what they would do you should do this
but they're not wearing my skin like but
I don't want to do that
it's not interesting for me that gets
like nothing going for me right
um but I still ask the question and I'm
so open the feedback and if you guys
have the answer
let's go like you go be president and
I'll go do I'll build this thing and my
thing will fund your campaign let's go
perfect running some AI School in 10
years I know we gotta jump but I have
one more question okay quick this is
scratching my own itch like you had
requested so I wanted to ask you this
and it was intuitive while we were
talking and I asked you this uh when we
first met it was many years ago
um but I want to ask it again because I
think it's evolved I think your answer
has evolved so at the end of the
hyper-conscious podcast which is now
next level University in some ways
thanks to you because you challenged us
to change our name yeah my question at
the end we both had the same question we
asked every guest at the end okay mine
was you've you evolve you change you
grow you adapt
um but there's something about you that
never changed okay and
I think that's the truest part of you
and I think there's a plus and a minus
to it okay uh I think the plus is that
you are now believe I think the minus is
you struggle to believe in yourself but
for you what about you never changed I
think I know the answer but I want to
know what your long form answer is what
never changed like throughout my whole
life yeah what's the common through line
of Evan Carmichael the one thing that
that never changed
I mean I would still say believe it's
just it's more
uh
because I'm aware of it I can more
consciously leverage it versus when I
was younger and I had no idea like if
he's resilient and he was doing all he
was probably doing lots of stuff that
was resilient at age eight he's like
what are you doing that's crazy Kevin
but like it comes off as weird and crazy
as opposed to no man I'm just resilient
like you suck I'm off crushing this
thing like let's go right it's like the
awareness I think in in a 95 year old
weapon is still believe but is even more
confident in it is even more living it
whatever that means right like I get
that's the theory I don't have the
specifics if I knew the specifics I'd be
doing it has what belief means to you
evolved
um and how you define it
not really
you know like since I came up with it I
think if you had asked me it at the
beginning if I was asking when I was 12
or something I don't know what I would
say uh but it hasn't really added any
more wrinkles like believing believe in
what you're doing
uh believe in yourself and believe that
it's going to work out it's like that's
that's the same thing I don't know what
I answered last time if it's close so
it's evolved or not but it's like
believing what you're doing believe in
yourself and believe it's going to work
out and most people see Believers just
believe in yourself
right as opposed to like no no believe
in like what you're doing passion like
the work you do matters and then also
believing that it will work out if you
continue that's why I care less about
like what happens this failure whatever
it's gonna work out dude it's gonna work
out I believe it's gonna work out even
though there's lots of losses winning
the war we're just losing a bunch of
battles as we figure out how to do it
well thank you for having us for this
battle we appreciate it let's go because
of you we believe in ourselves I'll
speak for myself I definitely believe in
myself more so I appreciate it I love it
thank you guys to see another awesome
conversation with me Kevin and Alan
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I need that more
belief what's the problem with everybody
it's like the problem is belief you
don't believe in yourself to do the next
thing you think the problem is how how
do I act that's not the problem the
problem is you don't believe in yourself
to do the how I can give you all the
hows in the world but until you believe
in your ability to do the how you're not
going to do the thing